we're told that vector a has magnitude 4
in direction 170 degrees from the
positive x-axis
vector b has magnitude 3 in direction
240 degrees from the positive x-axis
find the magnitude and direction of
vector a
plus vector b so pause this video and
see if you can have a go at that
all right now let's work through this
together and the way that i'm going to
approach it i'm going to represent each
vector in component form and then i'm
going to add the corresponding
components and from that
i'll try to figure out the magnitude and
the direction of the sum
so vector a what is its x component
well the change in x here there's
multiple ways that you could try to
do this using trigonometry but we've
reviewed this or gone over this in other
videos
the simplest way to think about it is
our change in x here is going to be the
length and we know vector a has
magnitude 4
times the cosine of the angle that the
vector makes with the positive x
axis cosine of 170 degrees and so that's
our x component right over here 4 times
cosine
of 170 degrees and then what's our
y component well our y component is
going to be this change in y
here and as we've reviewed in other
videos that's going to be the length
times the sine
of the angle we make with the positive
x-axis sine of 170 degrees
and we can maybe use a calculator in a
bit to get approximations for these
values
but then we can do the exact same thing
for vector b vector
b here is going to be by the same
logic its x component is going to be the
length of the vector
and it would be 3 they tell us that so
it's going to be 3
times the cosine of this angle 240
degrees
and then the y component is going to be
the length of our vector 3 times the
sine
of 240 degrees
now when we want to take the sum of the
two vectors let me write here vector
a plus vector b
i can just add the corresponding
components
this is going to be equal to 4
cosine of 170 degrees
plus 3 cosine
of 240 degrees and then the y component
is going to be 4 sine
of 170 degrees
plus 3 sine of
240 degrees and so let me get my
calculator out
to evaluate these we say 170 degrees we
take the cosine
times 4 that equals this
and then we're going to add to that i'll
open parentheses
we'll take the cosine of 240 240 cosine
times 3 close parentheses
is equal to this negative approximately
negative
5.44 so this is
approximately negative 5.44
and then if we were to take 170 degrees
take the sign of it multiply it by 4
and then to that i'm going to open
parentheses i'm going to take 240
degrees
take the sign multiply that times three
close my parentheses that is going to be
equal to approximately negative 1.90
so this is approximately negative
1.90 and this is consistent with our
intuition
if the sum has both negative components
that means it's going to be in the third
quadrant and if i were to do the head to
tail method of adding vectors if i were
to take vector b
and i were to put it right over here
we see that the resulting vector the sum
will sit
in the third quadrant it makes sense
that our x and y components would indeed
be negative now the question didn't ask
just to find the components of the sum
it asked to find the magnitude
and the direction of the resulting sum
and so to do that we just have to use a
little bit more
of our trigonometry and actually a
little bit of our geometry
for example our change in x is this
value right over here as we go from the
tail
to the tip it's negative 5.44
if we were just thinking in terms of
length right over here the absolute
value
this side would have length 5.44
and then similarly our change in y it's
negative we're going down in
y but if we were to just think in terms
of a triangle
the length on this side of a triangle is
1.90
and we can see from the pythagorean
theorem that
the length of our hypotenuse which is
the same thing as the magnitude of this
vector
squared is going to be equal to the sum
of the squares of these two sides
or another way of thinking about it is
the length of this vector the magnitude
of this vector
which we can write as the magnitude of
vector a plus
vector b is going to be equal to or i
should say approximately equal to since
we're already approximating these values
the principal root of 5.44 squared
and that's because i'm just thinking
about the absolute length of the side
i could also think about a change in x
but if i had a negative 5.44 and i
square that that would still become
positive
and then i'll have plus 1.90 squared and
i can get our calculator out for that
this is going to be
approximately equal to 5.44
squared plus 1.9
squared is equal to that take the square
root of that
it's approximately equal to 5.76
5.76 which is going to be our magnitude
and then to figure out the direction so
we essentially
want to figure out this angle right over
here
you might recognize that the tangent of
this angle theta right over here should
be
equal to and i'll do approximately equal
to since we're using these
approximations
our change in y over our change in x
so negative 1.90 over
negative 5.44
or we could say that theta is going to
be approximately equal to
the inverse tangent of negative 1.90
over negative 5.44
and we're going to see in a second
whether this is actually going to get us
the answer that we want so let's try
this out
if we were to take 1.9
negative divided by 5.44
negative that gets us that which makes
sense negative divided by negative
is a positive and now let's try to take
the inverse tangent
of that so here i press second and then
i'll do
inverse tangent so i'm getting 19.2
degrees approximately so this is saying
that this is
approximately 19.25 degrees
and my question to you is does that seem
right
well 19.25 degrees would put us in the
first quadrant it would give us a vector
that looks
something like this this would be
19.25 degrees
but clearly that's not the vector we're
talking about we're talking about a
vector in the third quadrant
and the reason why we got this result is
that when you take the inverse tangent
on most calculators
it's going to give you an angle that's
between negative 90 degrees and
positive 90 degrees well here we are at
an angle that puts us out in the third
quadrant
so we have to adjust and to adjust here
we just have to add 180 degrees
to get to the actual angle that we are
talking about
so in our situation the magnitude here
is going to be
approximately 5.76
and then the direction is going to be
approximately 19.25 plus 180 degrees
which is going to be
199.25
degrees and now we are done